the BMW motorrad days is the biggest BMW
motorcycle festival in the world for
three days the two withers take center
stage in the southern german town of
garmisch-partenkirchen
is the 13th time the event has been
staged and it's grown in popularity far
beyond Germany's borders this year
40,000 visitors from 40 countries came
to pay tribute to Beamer bikes
it was a laid-back friendly and very
informal atmosphere
among the many bikes on show were these
handcrafted one offs from the Berlin
firm urban motor their classic BMW s are
transformed into the clients
custom-built dream machines
nite chef it's all about passion
according to urban motors painted
diamond bag for mechanics old
motorcycles and old boxer engines so
they have the idea of making unique
models BMW is building block principle
means they can turn them into anything
the firm mainly works with bikes from
the 1970s and 80s there are many
similarities the engines and frames are
the same so they can be changed in any
way thinkable it could be a flat tracker
our cafe racer or a crossover model a
roadster whatever the customer wants so
I guess I'm going said come and sell as
much the bikes don't just look great
they also pack some real power a bmd
classic boxer sprint was put through its
paces in an eight mile drag race
sorry mom is equal in other yes via
nematode a plastic boxes it's a videsh
bus this is the fun part for Peter Donna
bag it's all about going head to head
and putting on a show he says it's not
about winning it's about letting your
bikes roar and leaving some rubber on
the road that's what it's about doesn't
see how it's up deployed
the urban motor team are certainly
enjoying the knockout competition a huge
adrenaline rush you open the throttle
and people love it this year also marks
a special anniversary the first BMW
motorcycle hit the market 90 years ago
some of the Marquis milestone machines
were out on display here like this are
23 from the very first production series
only around 3000 were built for this are
69 s with a top speed of 175 kilometers
an hour it was the fastest German
motorbike back in 1967
the f650 went into production in 1993 it
was BMWs most successful motorbike well
into the 2000s and there are no shortage
of future BMW fans in Germany the moto
rod days give junior bikers a chance to
put their motocross skills on show
you